so your aunt and uncle released a
statement in reaction to this
documentary oh I have seen that I
haven't seen that yes I have seen that
what was your reaction
honestly I I felt that it was very
gaslighting I feel like in that moment
they could have been humble and they
could have said like you know we're
sorry for the for the victims and and
they could have done that but instead
they didn't they didn't and that's
really really sad that they're still
protecting a pedophile it's very it's
very sad you know they call this
documentary derogatory they call it
sensationalized do you think that they
took the time to watch the documentary
I have no idea
um if they did or if they didn't uh but
like I said it was very gaslighting and
it doesn't show any support for the
actual victims and that is what the
documentary is all about
they called it encouragement they
literally said you need to come into the
room and we need to give you some
encouragement it really is their stories
shine through and it just shows like how
much they've come through you know
they've been through hell and back they
really have and so much control and just
a lot of fear that comes with iblp and
so it's so eye-opening and it's so
impactful to hear their stories and to
know that there is like always hope your
aunt and uncle say in their statement
that they think that things should be
repaired privately and you are a very
public person obviously this documentary
is being released to the public why do
you think it's important to do this in
front of the scenes
I think when you do something in a
private setting like they said in their
um in their statement that is when
things get swept under the rug that's
when lies happen that's when you can
kind of cover up oh it's not that bad
you know that kind of thing and no it is
idealp is damaging and what you say and
and your actions they need to they need
to match your words and actions need to
match and when they don't people are
going to call you out on it you know
it's not I'm not trying to bash my
family I still love them you know I I
miss the girls I miss the boys I miss my
cousins and I miss you know the family
moments we had that work quality time
but I have to protect my family I have
to protect my son I have to protect my
peace because this is completely equal
it is heartbreaking to hear that Amy
because they say in their statement that
they have love for everybody in the
family you just told me you have love
for everybody in the family where where
do all the relationships stand today I
have really
made some healthy boundaries
um in my life and as of right now
there's not many that I
um am in contact with I'm not going to
interact with someone who doesn't
protect children
okay so you are not in contact with your
aunt and uncle
no ma'am okay
um is there a is there a message that
you would want to send to them at this
point
I think honestly if you're not going to
protect your children I have to protect
mine you know and and you
yeah it's just a very a sticky situation
and very it's very sad and I I hope
their eyes can be open to the truth of
what iblp is and just honestly how
severe
it it is and how damaging it is and how
it's destroyed families and it silences
women and it you know if anything is
sensationalized it's iblp it's it's not
the fact that things are coming to light
this is a complete God thing and it's
perfect timing for all these victims to
come forth to tell their story and
that's truly what you know the
documentary is about
so maybe your messages I hope you watch
the documentary
I hope you watch it for for what it is
for sure yeah I hope you see that you
don't have to control no one needs a
thumb over them
um you know it's it's sad really truly
is are you in touch with people like
Jill who participated in the documentary
and I know Ginger just wrote a book yes
um Ginge I love Ginge Jill and I are
very close as well
um and I'm I'm it's I'm so proud of them
for the strength that they have to share
their stories you know they are victims
I'm not but I will be their cheerleader
for life as long as they are you know
getting the help and the and and the and
they're being healthy for their families
as well you know
um you gotta cut that cut out those
generational curses and
um I feel like they're doing such a
great job of just of just being who
they're supposed to be yes we were taken
advantage of so I don't like talking
about it you know I watch this
documentary and uh my heart really
shattered nearly every time Jill was on
screen because you can just feel her
pain through her message do you think
Jill's participation in this documentary
uh will impact the relationship that she
has with her family or I suppose the
lack thereof
I'm sure it's going to uh maybe wrinkle
even more you know the relationship but
at the same time Jill has to speak her
truth Jill has to tell her story you
know we're tired of the lies and I think
at this point everyone in the iblp
everything was covered up you know
everything was covered up and so we're
tired we're tired of it we're gonna
expose that truth because that's that's
what we're supposed to do you know it's
got to make the world a better place and
it's when Cults get exposed like this
that's that's really what it's about so
you you use the word cult to describe it
I do yes ma'am how do you think the
Duggar family will feel when they see
Jill's participation in this documentary
I just hope their eyes are opened that's
really all I can say maybe the kids will
start questioning like hey wait a minute
maybe maybe something's a little off you
know and maybe start questioning yeah
and I'm here I'm here whenever that
whenever that happens we have you as
very outspoken Jill is very outspoken
Ginger is very outspoken we get along
great we're seeing we're seeing a
pattern amongst some of the ladies in
the family that they're finding the
courage to use their voice and speak out
do you think more of the Duggar family
members will continue to defect from the
iblp I hope so I truly do
um I do think there's an opportunity
there you know we're being loud and
we're not gonna silence ourselves to
just make everything comfortable right
we want the world to know like just how
evil it truly is and so I think if they
get a chance to see it
um they might have to go to a library I
don't know but if they do get to see see
it I think it will start having them
question a lot and the four parts of
this documentary a huge theme is the
abuse that you uncover and really dive
deep into
um we learn a lot about the iblp and how
it covered up a lot of what Josh was
doing behind the scenes when did you
first learn about the horrific
misconduct on his part so I found out
just like the rest of the world it was
right before my wedding and his first
Scandal of Ashley Madison came out and I
was like I'm gonna need a glass of wine
what is hap what what it what just took
place there's a total shock total shock
I mean completely and the thing is that
even the last the most horrific lowest
of low you could you know you could
possibly look at and do
um I was texting him two weeks before he
was arrested we had we sent memes to
each other we were in contact
UM we would laugh together we had a lot
of inside jokes like I was saying and
it's just really sad of how you can live
such a double
scary evil life and you're fine with it
you can have kids and a family and smile
for the canvas and look so good and
shiny like like the documentary says and
then have such an evil double life do
you think that there is more abuse that
is going to come to light
honestly I I hate to say this but
probably because in the iblp you're not
allowed to get actual healing you're not
allowed to go to therapy it is frowned
upon I had no idea my mom didn't know I
didn't know and if and if we would have
known we would have gone straight to the
place we would have gotten them help we
would have you know obviously removed
them from the home as much as we could
we would have done whatever we could
have done to get them the help and the
resources they needed you know and to
start that healing process a long time
ago
and it just breaks my heart that it had
it had to be such a long time before all
this has come to light when was the last
time you spoke with Josh
two weeks before he was arrested I said
you know Josh I'm so glad that we were
to a place where you're you're a lot
healthier than you were and that um you
know you're getting progress had been
made I thought progress was being made I
truly did and again he had all of us all
of us fooled not just the world and
media but his own like flesh and blood
you know his own family we know that he
is now serving time Behind Bars and he
will be behind bars I think until 2032.
um do you know anything about his life
in prison is there any contact with with
you and with Anna or his family or with
him I have no idea and and I'm gonna
keep that uh health healthy boundary
there
have you tried to be a support system
for Anna or their children I tried I
have sent her emails I've sent I've sent
calls I have left voicemails I have
um put it on Instagram hey Anna love you
hell like you know I'm right here I've
tried to reach out to her and I don't
know if someone's monitoring her phone
is it that control and I don't know I
and it might take a little bit for her
to to comprehend all of this trauma you
know it's it's trauma at this point it's
disgusting and it's so sad and so
heartbreaking so I don't know where she
is mentally and I don't know if she's
getting help and I don't know if she's
getting therapy but I can't help someone
who doesn't want help
and that is the sad realization that I
had to come to that I'm here I've
reached out I've said there's bunk beds
for your kids we could we've got room we
can we can help and provide and you can
be safe and in a loving home so you've
tried and you've had only radio silence
radio silence okay you know that the day
will come where he is released from
prison how do you think Josh will be
welcomed back if at all do you think the
iblp will Embrace him do you think Anna
will Embrace him I hope to God they
don't Embrace that I hope that
I I don't I don't know at this point I
think he just deserves to be on an
island just far far far away from any
beautiful child that he could hurt
um it like it's it's crippling to me
like I I just like freeze up because
it's just so wrong and so evil
um
so I hope he just gets sent to an island
immediately you know
we got a place for you right over there
is retaliation at all a fear of yours
that the family or the iblp could do
something
um you know drastic in reaction to this
explosive documentary
I'm not afraid anymore
um I've gotten to the place where I'm
like okay God goes before me and I am
gonna speak up for those that can't
speak and I'm not afraid of anything I'm
really not you have been so outspoken
throughout the years what is next for
you as you continue to share this story
so there are a couple of agencies large
publishing agencies that have reached
out to me
um and I'm just like okay I don't know I
don't know what this looks like yet but
I there is a story there that people
don't know and I've dealt with a lot of
narcissistic people in my life and
I I don't know there might be a book in
in the future we'll see